this morning we look at the worry in
Taiwan that China will attack it someday
at a tense time for that whole region a
U.S warship yesterday sailed through the
Taiwan Straits separating the island
from China a narrow body of water there
and it followed days of Chinese military
drills around Taiwan the U.S Navy called
The Voyage a routine movement Elizabeth
Palmer looks now at how people the
people of Taiwan themselves are
preparing for a possible Invasion well
also hoping it never happens
taiwan's steep coast and mountainous
terrain make it something of a natural
Fortress
but China's people's Liberation Army
could well mount an attack anyway so
Taiwan is beefing up its military
in training with new U.S weapons
Michael Cole is an analyst for the
Republican Institute in Taiwan the aim
is not to defeat the pla
but to promise that the pla would suffer
such damage that it would not be worth
trying to invade Taiwan some civilians
want to be part of that deterrent
Joyce Chang is one of them and is it at
the back of your mind and the back of
your teammate's mind that one day this
could be for real you might have to
fight to defend Taiwan
sure
it's um no doubt about that
right now though everyone is praying it
won't come to that but when the
Taiwanese people woke up 10 days ago to
the news that Xi Jinping had ordered
military exercises in the sea and the
air around Taiwan they were reminded
that when he says he'll take control of
the island by force if necessary he
means it I know exactly how terrible a
war is Richard who retired as a Major
General in taiwan's Army a lightning
Chinese missile attack he says could
knock out critical infrastructure before
Taiwan or the U.S had time to react you
could wipe out 95 of the power in Taiwan
if there's a war wow
so you're saying there's the the
strategic planning overall is not
serious
not very serious
taiwan's military is getting more
serious but not everyone believes in
fighting off China the main kuomintang
political opposition wants closer links
and some want to outright join it but
young Taiwanese like Burton Lee and test
shoes say absolutely no way they were
proud to show me Life in this
flourishing democracy that they say
would be crushed by Chinese rule we've
all those that were afraid that
Democratic our religion our tradition
this tropical tropical island from its
Ultra high-tech semiconductor factories
to its rural Highlands where tea is
still picked by hand is now the most
dangerous in the confrontation between
the U.S and China
American leadership and probably the
world's economy all hanging the balance
for CBS mornings I'm Elizabeth Palmer in
Taipei